لم يكن صباحا هادئا على الحدود هنا ثمه ما
يجري عن بعد يهدد الامن مراقبه اوقعت
متسلل الى الحدود النرويجيه بين ايدي
الجنود كان قادما من الاراضي الروسيه
بطريقه غير شرعيه طالبا اللجوء هويه
المتسلل اثاره حفيظه عسكريين مقاتل روسي
في مجموعه فيجنر المسلحه انشق ووعد بتقديم
ادله وصفها بسيئه السمعه ضد مجموعه فاجنر
بعد تامين هروبه من روسيا
لم تعد تقدروا العنصر البشري كانوا بصدد
دفعنا نحو مصير المحتوم يتم تزويدنا
باسلحه خفيفه ودفعنا نحو النجوم الخسائر
كبيره في صفوف فاجنر في تقديري قد يصلوا
عدد الضحايا في كتيبه فقط نحو 20 قتيلا في
يوم واحدث
الصوت الاماميه في نوفمبر الماضي بعد
اربعه اشهر من القتال في اوكرانيا اختبا
بعدها بنفق روسي لمده شهرين وعبر النهر
هربا من الرؤوس الذين اطلقوا اعيره ناريه
وتعرضوه حتى وصل الى النرويج حسب تقريري
لصحيفه فين تايمز ذكر التقرير ان فاجنر
مددت لاندري عقده الى اجل غير مسمى رغم
انتهاء مدته وهددته بالانتقام اذا رفض
القتال بينما قال انه شاهد قوات الامن
الداخليه
تنفيذ عده عمليات تعذيب واعدام لجنودها
اذا رفضوا المشاركه في الحرب هروب القائد
السابق يسجل حاله انشقاق اولى عن مجموعه
الى الغرب منذ ان بدات الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه غذاء السالم العربيه